look at you Octavia Spencer I mean
you're an award-winning producer three
nominations the win for the help and I
do want to read you another movie of
yours again Oscar on the hidden figures
which got you to get to the White House
there's a picture and I think it's safe
to say
Octavia was quite happy to be at the
White House yeah
[Applause]
look at the picture box
he's saying close you're gonna hate
yourself in the White House
listen they told us that the president
wasn't gonna come and Janelle knew and
so she was actually across from me and I
didn't think anybody was watching I'm
like this is not a picture of Barack
Obama looking at you made him when he
was the president yes yes I did you know
I called him a bo personal relations no
I did meet him and it was funny I go to
the White House and the same thing he
wasn't supposed to be there and we go
and say he might and he comes out and
I'm with my wife this is actually a very
very big moment for me in my marriage
because we're sitting together and he
comes out with oh he's coming like
that's him so we like move up so we can
be at the front because he gives their
speeches around the holidays and he sees
me and he goes uh-huh Kevin Hart thank
you for making time for me coming to the
White House love you we love you and I
said you got to be kidding he looked at
me and and I had to plan so quite a turn
to my wife I say but you want to give me
[ __ ] in the house
[Applause]
like she couldn't a nice who's gonna be
like I'm a chill and since that moment
is an ongoing joke that we have but that
day was a special day for me just to
hear him I mom meow and will are you
still first in line for the biopic
because it has hand-picked you wasn't it
yeah no we talked about it yeah yeah
that would be oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]
you